the shadow education secretary Richard
Phillipson who joins us now thanks so
much for being with us we just heard
from Nadeem zahari and I showed him some
polling which shows how far ahead the
labor party is but he says it's
kierstama who should be worried right
now do you think that's right
uh no I don't think that's right I mean
we're not complacent about things and
the only pool that matters is the pool
that we see on general election day but
we've made massive progress as a party
and we're the only people setting out a
Clear Vision for how Britain could be
better and Labor's plan would mean we
deliver well-paid highly skilled jobs in
every corner of our country and we get
our economy growing once more something
we haven't seen over these last 12 years
and as you say you know you are doing
well in the polls and so I'm quite Keen
to try and find out a bit more of what
you say is a Clear Vision of what you
know a labor government would look like
what the country under labor would look
like you say you'll deliver more uh jobs
fairness I mean these are things that no
one would disagree with but I'm just
gonna I'm Keen to get a bit more of a
sense about you know the sort of values
and the principles uh that occur Style
with government would entail so would
you spend more money on public services
and than conservatives
well we don't yet know what the
situation will be with the Public
Finance as the conservatives crash the
economy and an incoming labor government
is likely to inherit a very difficult
situation and that will mean we have to
make difficult choices around public
money but we also have choices of course
as well about how we raise money that's
why I believe that we should end the tax
benefits that private schools enjoy and
invest in a brilliant State education
for every child driving up high
standards right across our schools but
you know we're not in a position right
now of course given the very uncertain
nature of the economy to set out exact
figures and what that first Labor budget
would look like
okay I will talk to you about the
education staff and give you the space
to talk about your policy um later in
the interview
um not completely clear from that
question whether you'd spend more on
public services than the conservatives
and how about immigration and we've got
record levels of immigration and nadims
are high we're saying that it's too high
the conservatives want to bring down
particularly illegal migration what's
Labor's position would you like to see
immigration higher or lower
I think my starting point is that
immigration has always been an important
part of our national story as a country
I wouldn't be stood here speaking to you
today we're not for the fact that my
grandparents came to this country from
Ireland worked in the NHS and helped to
build our country but I do recognize at
the same time that we need to make sure
we're investing in the skills of people
here that we're giving everyone the
opportunity to succeed so there is a
balance to strike and that's why we
would maintain a point-space system
where it comes to immigration
okay and that's clear on the
points-based system certainly um but can
we talk about strikes now because again
it's another issue that I think so many
people will have you know big questions
about and public sector workers want a
pay rise to match inflation so inflation
obviously currently around 11 Nadeem
zahari says that would be unsustainable
it'll be unaffordable what is Labor's
position would you give inflation
matching pay Rises to public sector
workers
I completely recognize that right across
our Public Services whether that's
nurses or teachers they've been terribly
let down by this government and they
want a fair deal and that is around pay
but it's also about terms and conditions
the fact that so many people working in
our public services are burnt out feel
that they have a government that is
completely abandoned them under the last
Labor government we made sure that we
invested in our Workforce that we made
sure they were paid properly for the
amazing job that they are doing and I
think that is incredibly important but
as I say pay is one very important
element of this but if you speak to head
teachers or School support staff as I do
right across the country they just feel
you know overworked let down and really
badly demoralized and that's why it'll
be the job of an incoming labor
government to demonstrate that we want
to work with the people the amazing
people in our public services to make
sure that you don't have to wait months
on end to get access to a hospital
appointment the fact that children in
all of our schools have opportunities to
succeed and that we don't end up in this
position as we are now where staff are
having to put their hands in their own
pocket in order to make sure that
children don't go hungry when they
arrive at school and Labor's plan around
breakfast clubs making sure that every
child in our country gets a brilliant
start to the day is part of how we make
life a lot better and easier for staff
working in our Public Services too and I
just want to come back because the
question was specifically about pay
um you say that you would like to see a
fair deal a public sector workers should
be paid properly but but you know the
difficult thing is working out what that
means would you like to see inflation
matching pay rises in the public sector
I want to see a fair deal for all of our
workers right across Public Services of
course this is all about negotiation and
compromise
they want to see a fair deal the
question is what is that don't negotiate
well I do think it means recognizing the
pressure that people are under right now
but also over the last 12 years uh pay
hasn't been keeping up with demands that
workers in our Vital services are facing
but you can't get to a position of
agreement if you're not prepared to even
have that conversation and what I hear
time and again you know whether it's
real or our schools or the Health
Service ministers are just not prepared
to sit down and talk about these issues
properly we won't get an agreement and
we won't get a negotiated settlement but
all sides can live with if ministers
just say well there's nothing to do with
me you know if I was Secretary of State
for Education I'd be around the table
try to get a solution working with trade
unions to find a find a way through all
of this not stalking tension as
ministers all too often seem intent on
doing
um I don't know what um you know we
started the interview talking about the
polls it's pretty clear how well they
were doing with the polls if they were
replicated in a general election like
that result in Chester then you would
have a majority so I get you know that
there is obviously a desire in Labor uh
right now to not scare the horses
effectively to kind of play it safe and
then you'll hopefully get as you say say
uh you know that majority at the next
election but
I guess there's a bit of a frustration
sometimes interviewing people from labor
when it does feel like you're being a
bit reluctant to nail your colors to the
Mast or on public except to pay for
example it's almost like you don't want
to put off either side in the debate by
saying that you want a fair deal you
want everyone to talk but I'm not really
clear on whether or not you think that
inflation matching pay Rises are
unaffordable or if you're saying that
it's something that actually the
government should do whatever happens
foreign
because I think trust in politics
matters and I'm not going to make
promises this morning to you that I
don't feel confident I can deliver I
think that's been what so what's been so
corrosive to our politics in recent
years is Tory politicians in particular
saying one thing and doing another so
yes absolutely I want to see a better
deal for the brilliant people that work
right across our education system and a
part of that is around the choices that
we make around how we find investment
and our policy on private schools around
ending those tax breaks and putting that
1.7 billion pounds into more teachers in
our classrooms into better mental health
support for all of our children and in
making sure that all of our staff are
properly supported that's one I think
really straightforward way the
government right now could be doing
things differently and that's a clear
divide that you see between labor and
the conservatives our focus on high
standards and all of our brilliant State
schools but on driving up standards
further and Richie sunac who isn't
prepared to stand up to the vested
interests in his own party and isn't
prepared to do what's right by children
and families in our country
um you're also calling for a regulatory
investigation into private schools just
to explain what that's about
seen uh for years now are fees going up
often very substantially and you know I
think there needs to be a full
investigation into whether that market
is operating effectively we've heard
Lots about landish claims from Jeremy
Hunt and from Rishi suunak and others
about the impact of Labor's policy which
I just don't think are born out by the
evidence but if you look at the fees
that private schools are charging right
now they have gone up Way Beyond
earnings in cash terms and I think it is
important that the CME investigate this
matter and see whether this Market is
working properly and I think it does now
fall to the Secretary of State for
education to whom I've written to make
sure that matter is referred to the CME
and that they look into it but who's
whose side is she on is she on the side
of parents on the side of children on
delivering a brilliant education for all
of our children or is she not prepared
either the stand up to the vested
interests in our own party
okay thank you very much for being on
the program uh this morning Bridget
Phillips in there for the labor party